investors
being an entrepreneur is hard having
supportive and caring investors helps
fred wilson how do you write a business
plan for investors
it doesn't matter if you have a business
degree it doesn't matter if you
graduated from university college high
school
or the school of hard knocks it doesn't
matter what your last name is
what your skin color is how old you are
or whether you wear pants or a skirt
i used to be a venture capitalist a vc
people came to me to raise big money for
their businesses
i'm talking 500 000 to 15 million
dollars kind of money
and today i'm going to share with you
the three most important things i look
for
before inviting someone in to see me
99.9 of business plans got rejected
only the 0.1 percent of entrepreneurs
who followed these three
simple rules got invited to a meeting
with us
so if you're thinking about raising
capital or just want an education
as to how the process works you'll want
to pay attention to this one
number one executive summary the
executive summary is the first
thing an investor venture capitalist
angel banker and so on
looks at it's one to three pages at the
beginning of your business plan that
summarizes the whole opportunity
write it last make it important
keep it simple there was an expression
in the vc world that an executive
summary had to pass the grandmother test
meaning that it had to be written in
plain english so that your grandmother
could understand it
most business plans are filled with so
much jargon and technical terms
that investors get lost remember
investors are generalists
not specialists they don't know your
business like you do
it's your job to make it easy for them
to understand the opportunity
if they can't understand how they're
going to make money from your executive
summary
then your entire business plan goes to
the trash can
and that's your fault keep it
simple number two
management team assuming they like your
executive summary the next thing to look
at
is your management team they want to see
what kind of experience you have
have you done this before do you have
any startup experience
are you the right person to actually
execute this idea of yours
one of the biggest problems with most
startup companies is an incomplete
management team
for example you've got a founder who
can't sell and doesn't have a sales
person
or you've got a tech company without a
cto or everybody involved is young and
this is the first thing they're trying
all of those things scream risk for an
investor
to give yourself the best chance at a
yes find people to complement your team
it could be someone who's a partner a
full-time or part-time employee
or even a member on your board of
advisors pro
tip create a board of advisors get
respected people to lend their name to
your company
so it doesn't look like it's just you
for example if nobody who really
understands finances is on your team
that's going to worry an investor get
your accountant to join your board of
advisors to add credibility
and make investors feel more comfortable
number three financials investors want
to know that they're going to get a
return on their investment
banks for example want to know that you
can pay them back and they'll likely
want your house as collateral
angel or vc investors will want to see
that your business can give them an
average annual return of 30 percent on
their investment they want to see that
you can grow
quickly and that someone is likely to
buy you out
they want to be in and out of your
business in six to eight years
can they get that kind of return through
your financials
if they can't they're out also make sure
that you understand
every number on your financial
projections they're going to test your
assumptions and if you stumble
you're going to lose them the next step
you'll need to send an entire business
plan in but those are the three
main sections investors will look at if
you pass a test on those three then the
investor will likely read the rest of
the plan
but would be thinking in the back of his
or her head i'd like to meet this
entrepreneur
and that's what you want that first
meeting where you can show your passion
and get them excited about the
opportunity with you
it's not about having a business degree
you don't need it to write a business
plan
your plan just has to make sense make it
easy for investors to understand your
business
and you're that much closer to getting a
yes from them
believe
you